et maintenant
où
voici tonie marshall et jean paul
gaultier
ouais
bonsoir familles d'enfants jean-paul
alors tenir vous êtes une enfant de la
balle
puisque vous êtes la fille de bill
marchal acteur réalisateur américain le
mari de michelle morgant à une époque
est donc le grand père de la fameuse
sarah marshall et oui du parent d'un
petit peu que ça marche assez manière
saisonnière
voilà mais je la connais très peu mais
on s'est vus il ya assez longtemps avant
qu'elle épouse j'ai oublié son nom
alexandre alexandre anthony voilà ils
font beaucoup tous les deux mais il
paraît donc voulu avec la fille donc de
belmarsh a et de micheline presle axel
évidemment cette grande actrice qu'on
adore tous micheline presle voilà et
quand vous étiez enfant vous dormiez
dans une chambre qui jouxtait la salle
de projection du studio des ursulines
alors quand il était tout petit vous
entendiez leçon et puis ensuite devenues
copines avec l'ouvreuse et puis elle
vous laisser rentrer dans la salle du
studio des ursulines
comme ça vous avez vu très jeunes des
films de godard de bergman les einstein
enfin vraiment vous avez une formation
très précoce j'avais la cabine du
projectionniste était à peu près on
était séparés par une cour de trois
mètres et donc l'été particulièrement il
aller fumer une clope sur le l'escalier
en métal et donc il ouvrait la porte de
la cabine et j'ai donc vécu les connu lé
film en entier par le son je connais
alexandre nevsky pratiquement
phonétiquement etc voilà alors vous avez
fait plein de films vous à votre tour
ensuite le plus connu disons c'est vénus
beauté institut un qui a été nominé sept
fois aux césars qu'elle a décroché
quatre césar du meilleur film du
meilleur scénario de la meilleure
réalisatrice et meilleur espoir féminin
pour la fameuse audrey tautou qui depuis
a fait
audrey tautou non peut-être que tu la
connais mieux sous le nom de sa mère
katherine qui lui coule thunder bay
dernier jean gt france boutiques dont
judith godrèche est venu parler ici ceci
devrait alors jean paul gaultier vous en
plus des activités qui porte votre nom
va pas toutes les énumérer parce que ça
commence à faire pas mal
vous avez signé en mars dernier votre
première connexion pour hermès ou vous
revisiter les grands classiques de la
maison dans un esprit
voilà moderniser gauthier voilà ludique
nous continuer à travailler pour le
cinéma et le spectacle vous êtes occupé
de peter greenaway de caro et jeunet de
besson d'almodovar de madonna d'yvette
horner de johnny hallyday et de sylvie
vartan
alors j'ai lu dans une interview j'ai lu
dans une interview récemment terre d'un
suivi vartan les autorités content
d'elle appels à frais contente dans son
bouquin ça donc on a lu le bouquin de
sylvie vartan et à aucun moment elle se
plaint de vous alors la seule chose qui
aurait pu arriver c'est qu'elle oublie
de parler vous mais elle vit pas de mal
de vous dans son bouquin alors je sais
pas je me demande je me demande si en
fin de compte j'ai pas lu un autre livre
arrêts ouais parce que je sais pas il y
en a pas deux sur sylvie vartan 1
celui là il est écrit par elle dans
celui qui est écrit par elle ne parle
pas du tout du tout car ça doit être
l'hôte écrit par un journaliste jay
paraît que j'ai lu et je croyais que
c'était celui 1 où il ya une ville une
couverture pas très généreux vertueux
voilà c'est pas elle on a vraiment hâte
qu'elle dit rien contre vous et l'eau
mais simplement de parler de vous c'est
vrai
alors justement si vous deviez relooké
vincent peillon quand même un homme
politique et bull qui est plutôt beau
gosse vous dire les choses un kéké gens
travailleurs tout mais au niveau du look
est ce que vous pensez qu'il doit rester
comme ça pour pour faire sérieux pour
faire hommes politiques la cravate le
costume pour être très honnête ça me
fascine pas tellement le fait d'
habiller comment les politiciens parce
que je trouve que bon ils ont certaines
règles à appliquer tout bon ben voilà
les hyper classer le mieux non pour eux
habillés un animateur télé ça veut
centrer jean-paul moi par exemple la
rentrée qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez
parce que ça fait quand même très bien
18 ans je suis habillé comme bien trop
c'est comme une espèce d'image de marque
ont regardé mon amie ma région
jean paul gaultier ce que vous faites
des fautes de goût aux sûrement plein on
s'est déjà retrouvé en train de faire
des courses le dimanche matin avec un
sur mer et des mocassins ça vous est
arrivé ça ce genre de qui peut devenir
bien ceci bien mais qui peut devenir
bien ça dépend comme tout est fait est
fait quoi il est des choses qui sont à
une époque horrible tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire puis après qu il au contraire
qu'on trouve ont pas su plaintes de
différents et on trouve ça plutôt rigolo
et bien vous êtes déjà retrouvé au
marcel devant un match de foot par
exemple
ben non je regarde pas et ouais je foute
alors déjà à l'église en mini jupe avec
des lunettes wars et jamel ait ben je
porte une jupe l'équipe je le porte de
temps à autre mais elle est rarement
demain gsk demain après midi sur france
absolument absolument je sais pas un
match de foot non à 15h30 sur france 5
il ya un documentaire de tonie marshall
sur jean paul gaultier voilà alors au
début quand on vous a dit de faire un
documentaire vous êtes dit oui l'a
jamais fait de documentaires qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire
et puis
vous paraît que vous dites oh là là je
vais pas voir une équipe sur le dos
pendant cinq mois donc au départ c'était
pas c'est pas évident savait pas encore
que celle est tonie marshall
quand j'ai su que c'était elle et ce qui
les a réunis c'est un film un film sur
la mode un film des années 50 un film de
jacques becker qui s'appelle pas le bal
à dont l'héroïne est votre maman
micheline presle
il se trouve que micheline presle vous
vous l'adorez dire vous l'avait habillée
pour le pro pour les césar on voit ça la
fin du documentaire d'ailleurs mais oui
tout à fait puisque pour moi je suis un
enfant de la télé on va dire donc gg je
regardais la télé tue tout gamin je me
souviens qu'à un moment j'avais vu
l'émission des folies bergères sur les
folies bergères dont je voulais à
billets je voulais faire des costumes
pour les folies bergères ça a commencé
comme ça et puis après j'ai vu falbala
et là c'était le coup de foudre totale
je dis non c'est la mode ça je devais
avoir j'ai pas 12 ans 10 12 ans c'est
quand même le probablement le seul film
qui raconte processus d'une collection
de haute couture du début jusqu'à la fin
se dire qu'après ça c'était la vérité
c'était ma bible en quelques sortes
voilà selon jacques becker très beau
film alors le documentaire s'appelle les
falbalas de jean paul gaultier est pas
pour rien donc vous parler de votre vie
professionnelle et puis de votre vie
privée leur cheminement professionnel on
apprend que vous dessinez deux
collections par an dont vous êtes
toujours dans l'urgence quoi c'est ouais
ouais c'est un petit peu c'est ça le
rythme de la mode c'est c'est assez
étonnant
en plus on peut faire quelquefois des
collections qui sont plusieurs saisons
un même temps enfin la cheville à la
fois sur l'été et l'hiver enfin alors on
découvre aussi dans ce documentaire vous
laisser appeler monsieur comme coach
essaie d appeler mademoiselle jusqu'à
présent que jean-paul ou d'abord parce
qu'on n'était pas nombreux
j'ai commencé par des affaires du
prêt-à-porter c'était pas la même façon
là même le même vocabulaire on va dire
que dans la couture où j'ai commencé et
en insistant
mais là comme j'ai pris certaines
personnes certaines comment met-on la
première d'atelier qui venait de la
couture elle avait l'habitude de dire
monsieur pascal travailler avec monsieur
givenchy donc ça a été monsieur donc je
me suis retrouvée d'un seul coup paf
avec monsieur ouais ça va un peu chanel
qua non sauf que c'était mademoiselle
donc là elle m'a pas dit mademoiselle
sera peut-être un peu plus étonné c'est
le même rituel
mademoiselle alors on parle de votre vie
privée aussi d'une façon assez franche
de tout un jeu trop rares sinon c'est
vrai c'est assez
ouais ouais ouais quand j'ai cassé le
documentaire vous allez vite et une
psychanalyse sûrement mais oui c'est ça
si je disais en fin de compte chez merci
tony c'est tout à fait ça bien alors
tous les deux vous allez regarder la
caméra où il ya le rouge
et vous allez dire en même temps si vous
le dit pas en même temps ça marchera
parce que pas être synchro attention pas
être synchro je vous donnais un top vous
dites mallet d'auxerre jeu rien à 3
attention 2 3
magnéto serge c'est quoi cette histoire
me pourris tous les invités attention
aux mêmes c'était bien un 2 x 2 3 mais
nie tout ça